what is up guys and welcome back to the
Jenna and Julian podcast this week we
have this episode of a 15 hour special
guest this week is joy Womack who is a
very good friend of mine in ours but
also way more than that and we'll get to
all on that yeah
first things first this podcast is
brought to you by Squarespace
Squarespace is one of the easiest ways I
love schedule is right at lesson
Thursday you have some of the most
professional looking templates for you
really clean really easy to use that
work on mobile online store comes with
it great customer support check it out
at squarespace.com we'll talk more about
that later you can get a discount at
squarespace.com slash Jenna Julianne
so we will get more into that later but
yes so we are joined today by joy wall
Mac and joy is an incredible human being
probably one of the coolest guests gasp
how again we're not even joking
that's no stabbing any of our other
guests juju I grew up together yeah yeah
joy is randomly is the sister of my best
friend chase who's been in a lot of my
stuff up you know how chases like my
childhood best friend grew up together
then you guys moved to Texas and then I
tried to grow up with you in Texas - I
was just out there and there's nine of
you nine brothers and sisters yeah
there's six boys and three girls there's
that there's one set of triplets nine
Womack's
let's like add people that we kind of
collected yes I'm so joy is a dancer oh
and these bars were here we don't man
just leave a mess this is
Joy's company called the Prima bar
they're amazing energy bars that you've
created and this is your brand now ah
but they're primarily marketed towards
dancers yeah they're like made with
dancers in mind they're [ __ ] good and
addicting
no they're very very good um they're
like really tasty and they have all 100%
natural so it's not like they're you
guys not like a bar like it tastes like
something that your mom might make for
you yeah you can taste the ingredients
in here like there what coconut pecan or
something yeah that was like my favorite
flavors right so we went that one yeah
yeah no we go ham on these things you
thank you for them okay no probably be
gone by tomorrow I start no the judging
home didn't find our energy well we got
huh I like sit in that cream bar offices
getting all the energy that's about a
dancer that's good for me so the reason
why we say joy is an interesting
character is because she really if she
has some incredible stories Joy's a
dancer and she's had a history of
dancing in Russia joy was you were the
first American ever graduated from the
Bulls question for them and also to ever
have a contract with the butcher right
yeah so that's incredible I mean that's
that's like the New York Times wrote
about Ryan and it's very very impressive
stuff and now you're currently you're
visiting a lifer yeah I mean teaching
here at the school I swear which is
really fun yeah and they're so cute yeah
and you doing like a lot of TJ yeah I'm
not just doing like Oh in the morning is
that rain oh my gosh I can get ready
yeah that's right it's raining sorry
anyways how do you teach yeah right now
yes you teach I'm just ballet
I teach ballet I can do contemporary
dance so I I'm also teaching character
dancing what's character dance
that's like national days and so I'm
like kids let's learn Russian dance I'm
not getting like man you're only in
Russian right I speak Russian
I understand French can you tell us how
to say Jenna Julianne podcast in Russia
uh portgas Jenna Julian I took fashion
for a year and I can only say things
like Ravi ta-da yeah where's that mean
that's what you mean by a sweet onion
right
I know well we're not done yet no we're
not done getting started
yeah you wear a million hats yeah and
you're currently with the Kremlin yeah
in Moscow good answer
your principal dancer and so you're
still your contract is with them but
you're on a break right now you're out
here teaching but I'm I'm really lucky
to sort of be with them because they
sort of let me do whatever I want like
I'm going with my partner to Hong Kong
um to be on the jury and like dance for
the Asian from free and then I'm going
to Singapore so I just sort of go yeah I
mean your your hot item like people want
you well hopefully yeah that's very cool
I mean it's it's a really wild story how
you went over there and say this giant
name for yourself like you made waves
here I went to blows well I mean it was
just sort of this kind of opportunity
that I couldn't say no to and it's
really interesting how life works like
that way sometimes that's the only door
that's like open and okay we're gonna
walk through it yeah yeah yeah
absolutely and you grew up obviously
grew up dancing your whole life
no and you spent you spent a lot of time
dancing in Santa Monica for you movie
they did Ilana what ballet were you at
Texas oh my gosh Alexis that was crazy
because I didn't want to move yeah I'm
saying like I love my place here that's
going to Gina and for me I thought it
was like oh I'm gonna have to do it by
this ballet let's just be honest sit in
Austin Texas yeah welcome here no Monica
is way oh yeah and so we kind of did
like hit or miss and then we found this
amazing teacher and like actually thinks
to her that's how I got interested in
like the Russian style of dancing so a
fly had never moved to Texas I wouldn't
have like sort of done what I what I've
done so yeah that's right yeah yeah but
then you ended up like enjoying Texas
you go back then yeah no but the thing
about me I'm very lame I couldn't ride a
car I'm like 21 so I'm like mom can you
uh dye me ballet
Wow
how'd you know I just can't even be
bothered like my hand handle last night
was going out and she's like oh my
triple-a card my life so it's like I
forget half of those things in like five
different play yeah I'm sorry um so you
have a very interesting period of time
when you went to the bolshoy and you're
partying with the bullsh right that was
not real isn't yeah it's this some [ __ ]
guys so yeah well I guess we can just
mean it you spoke out about some gangs
now we're going on at the Bolshoi
Academy that were less than look Academy
the company um the entire Club the
Academy was so was such a great
experience because they really sort of
turned a blind eye for the fact that I
was American like here
she loves to and she's working and they
gave me sort of an opportunity where
nobody else would have even dare to and
they gave me two principal roles like
and I got to dance on there cuz there's
always that [ __ ] good no she really
she seriously should pay his back ya
know but um then I got to the company
and it just I mean it's not necessarily
like the company's fault but honestly
Russia is is definitely behind writing
us like in the way things operate so
they weren't really set up to like have
foreigners working for them so it was
like this whole kind of like oh how do
we do this just sort of like a lot of
different things and then um big
institutions in Russia I can be corrupt
you know I'm very grateful for the whole
experience I learned so much through it
um and I think the biggest thing I
learned just like don't compromise your
morals because the second you start
doing it you're gonna have to keep doing
it oh yeah either stand up for what you
believe in
or you say like alright I'm just gonna
do it the way everyone else does so I
mean there was a definitely like three
big moments where I had to say with okay
am I going to do this is because that's
what everybody else is doing or am I not
so it's getting and you're you're what
16 when you over there like how old are
you I moved over there when I just
turned 15 like that's unreal think about
that
second you were 15 years old and moved
to a different country by yourself yeah
you're a yummy highest-level make a real
terrible that is for and dealing with
all sorts of different societal and you
can't trust the adults that you're being
surrounded with but I think I was sort
of I didn't even understand that I
couldn't have contrasted yeah and though
I think hardest thing was like my dad
literally just like put me on a plane
he's like all right see you yeah bye I
got there treshon it's like okay what do
i do I don't even know how to ask how to
get to school but as a whole did you
enjoy your time in Russia you're still
living there now no I love it and I'm
really grateful for the experience and
it's given me such a unique perspective
and I've gotten to do a lot of things
that people aged and haven't even gone
on the time but learning a new language
learning a new kind of like how people
work and just really I mean I think
there's a lot to say to you know for the
u.s. to have like people going and
traveling because so many people are
just like stuff in there like you know
everything is so convenient here in this
days like you just call your uber or
whatever you order your grabbing a girl
right and you experience that at such a
young age
yeah really got a registered for at
other side of the world I mean I I get
like I get like reverse culture shock
coming back to the United States like
this being in LA I feel like I'm like on
vacation at the Ritz I don't really like
I like my bed is so soft that people are
so nice like what even is this yeah we
like a soft edge and they're friendly
people oh my gosh no that's great people
would just tell you how it is they're
like I don't like you don't like what
you're about like not having it yeah and
that's it you know they're really and
you've had some less than awesome
experiences on the streets and stuff
yeah tell us is it this man this is
mostly because you're a female an
American or is it just I think I mean
there's a really interesting thing going
on
that people are talking about and I
think that the United States focuses a
lot on like internal problems versus
what's going on in the world and right
you've got I mean I just read an article
about that's like you've got a couple of
new sources that control all the news
that people need is a street and like
nobody knows what's actually even going
on in the world you know until you get
my deal done love conspiracy theories I
love to dig into deep holes on the
internet human Adi
yeah we did I mean for people that care
enough to be skeptical of what we're
being told we like to find our
information in other places
yeah absolutely and you're 100% right no
you take Russia where like 99 percent of
the media is controlled by the Kremlin
you know so that's like take it or leave
it that's that's what's going on so what
you have are people who don't get their
news from the internet so they're not
getting sort of people are very
skeptical of the of news on the internet
very skeptical of social media like it's
only now that people are really like
starting to even use Facebook in Moscow
like you've got their own social media
stuff and that you post anything that's
like anti like patriotic and people are
on you like your friends are on like
people feel so passionate about one more
cookie Wow like like you walk down the
street and there's like food including
food including food including like I
work for the Kremlin like yay Putin or
whatever but um like don't you dare not
even toe the party line yeah wow that's
so wild
that's so ever and it is different
because at least here part of being an
American is that we celebrate you being
able to speak them against the
government and have your own opinion and
it's difficult to imagine living in a
place where your own friends and family
what sort of disown you or hate you
having an opinion no you know what I
mean I mean in my teacher she's so
wonderful like she's taking a rest to
like take me on the weird American in
the company you know was like obsessed
with working out or whatever and the
word American
and she's she like psychos like yeah
you're weird that I'm just like good to
see creature
yeah you're weird I'm a secret sea
creature um no and she will be like like
then I've noticed it even in the past
year she's like gotten very politicized
Wow like where she I didn't even care
about like who I was like two years ago
Wow like and she'll be like you know
that's your American side coming out
that's why you know that you just have
too many ideas like your tries trying to
do it to definitely that's not the way
we do things I'm and like well how do
you change and grow and like write even
improve if you're just okay with being
like right you know you know the game
like the walk were getting more animal
whack-a-mole that is how living in
Russia is like don't stick your head up
don't stick your head up or I'm gonna
hit it down speak out
don't be different it's very intense is
a pretty incredible analogy that is very
knowledge II if we were like a new
source we would market this article as
she's like yeah like shot now that I've
like said I'm saying
no no because you're saying it in a way
that makes sense and your city you're
also saying exactly you're not you know
having the problems come right I mean
the other thing is the fact that like
definitely in Russia there's a culture
of fear and there's a culture of
skepticism and I mean I would be afraid
even saying these things yeah right like
on skype to my own parents yeah like
I've had people willing send me like
hate mail
I've had people like post a poem about
how I packed my bags on my apartment
door like how did they find me
you know God like and like had people
like I've talked and just things like
that but there's like a reason why I'm
there and I've been there for so long
I'm very grateful for everything but I
think like it's it's Russia the trend is
not upward much of it that way yeah they
are and they feel like they are at war
with America with the west and with
Western values
it is so homophobic it is so it's like
gone towards this trend like uber
Orthodox like sort of like marrying of
the church in the state and not in a
good way
like now well I recommend all the
viewers to watch movie called Leviathan
Leviathan yeah like watch the Wi-Fi oh
my god is it not much better is it it's
no it's a movie that got nominated for
Best Foreign Language Film like it
didn't win an Oscar okay I have a
conspiracy but I know I'm not gonna
watch me okay it's so fun guys yeah we
will do yes like if you want to cry your
eyes out - yeah it sounds like it's real
yeah yeah I mean see just hearing you
talking about this stuff is very intense
anyway let's take it on the lighter
break it really quick and I just want
you to know that we really appreciate
you being open about everything with us
and talking to us about your life
because right I feel like it's not an
easy thing to just like discuss but oh
and joy also is a fan of the gingely
pocket like does listen I love it I've
watched every episode almost thank you
well now your episode 50 oh my god I
can't believe I'm so honored yeah like
you guys are my connection like I
learned about snapchat what else did I
learn about I like cultivate or I
learned about eyelashes what else better
you know I learned about so many things
really cuz Jenna Julia thought yeah
because we don't have access to um -
Hulu or Netflix or like any TV I will be
like so I yeah
like for me the way I like get my
entertainment or like the way I just
like get out of my like ballet obsession
like is I just like YouTube is like
really fun so that that's my well it
sounded like you had access to
Squarespace which talked about yourself
swirlix is sponsoring today's podcast
Thank You Squarespace thank you if any
of you guys have an online shop a blog
whatever it is go to Squarespace and
check it out you can get a free trial no
credit card needed and basically you
have all the control in the world but at
the same time it looks like it's
professionally done when we you know
with Jen and I talk about all the time
when we get sponsored by Squarespace
create no excuse not to have a website
no excuses now because you know back
when we were blogging and it was not
easy there were so many things that you
had to do right to just make it look
like a shitty website and now you do
nothing on Squarespace it looks
beautiful
today works yeah it comes with an online
shop for free works on mobile check it
out Squarespace comm product code Jenna
Julian Squarespace complex Jenna Julian
you get a nice little discount for
yourself so you can check it out but if
you want to do it for free do the free
trial no credit card needed so check it
out at Squarespace Evan a story yeah
funny story about Squarespace so my
brother is like trying to like how much
there's a funny story because it
involves YouTube yeah okay so okay so my
brother's like you know there's like
polish cop like soon when you get the
website ready like what do you have
anything done and I'm like getting these
like brand name email blasts like on
hours and the night about this thing and
I'm like oh my god it just looks
[ __ ] I decided it looks like 1995
you know and then I like for some reason
I think I was like you know working out
or something and I was like you know
what I'm just gonna do it so I used your
guys's code I built a better-looking
website but like yeah okay like
like using their like coat and then my
brother had probably spent like two
months doing yeah yeah bars on scruffy
it's on okay we haven't changed the like
thing yet anyway long story start I've
like have way too many jobs for parking
no I heard all about that debacle when
you're when you brother spent a lot of
time I was looking I'm shocked
just kidding I'm not shocked so so you
look at my Squarespace it's the premium
it's like your guys's code and so I get
it works like a charm guys anyway hurry
all so do it product really so easy it
literally took me 30 minutes oh my god
knew everyone anyway 10 more life from
Siberia so from society okay yeah from
Siberia it can work for you really
inside but yeah it was like a joke in
our Russian class look if you didn't get
something right Billy go you're just
we're gonna send you on the side beer
you don't want to go to Siberia I know
that desolate way to joke we're gonna
send you a way to save you
guys if you don't go to Squarespace
you're going to say very honest thing
what's worse is like a work that should
be um so let's switch gears a little bit
you are out here you're doing a lot of
teaching of dancing and you know you're
getting places that are like come teach
you know while you're in town but you're
also marketing your brand now this is
your bring I'm trying to Chile you have
a vlog channel which I I watch I enjoy
hit me up a while ago was telling me I
want to start blogging can you give you
some tips and I did my best it was
probably like crappy advisor ever but
she's you've been vlogging yeah like
you're trying which is like it's the
smartest thing I feel like you could do
and a life like yours yeah you know just
long it let's share with the world
because so as much as you can safely do
I um people will genuinely be interested
in your life because you have the
absolute least we're gonna link my stuff
load especially her vlog channels ya
know so you're trying to build this
brand and you're trying to make some
happen
do you have an idea of like what you'd
like to do or where you like this whole
thing to go yeah I do have an idea and I
think I really do have to say like thank
you guys so much for like giving me like
the inspiration and like when you
message me or like go and do it I I
don't know I meant so much and I was
like yeah you know what I'm gonna do it
and
well you're clearly a person who knows
how to go and do no no it's it really
did mean a lot I know no worries um yeah
it's gonna be okay why don't you have a
prima boy okay cuz I should tell you
that I want to eat it like next to the
mic
like I just well basically like the boom
bar is like one of the products that I
want to do because like it comes like
project prima is kind of like thing like
incumbents that and like that comes from
the desire from when I was 10 years old
there was nobody can ask for advice
right I told my mom was like mom I want
to be fresh London so she's like what
even are you like to control back
highlighted you know like this is what I
want to do and there was no sort of like
how to guide yeah right and what I
wanted to build is sort of like this
interactive community of like hey if you
want to be a professional dancer even if
you want to be an adult student who does
like dance here's some trips like some
tricks and some tips on how to do it I
mean here some products that it's gonna
like that's going to make your life
better and also I mean I'm someone who
suffered from extreme eating disorders
like that's where this comes from right
is I wanted to make a food that dancers
can trust because I mean it's so hard
especially when you're like at that
professional level there's such a like
huge pressure on you to have the right
aesthetic yeah and that aesthetic is
almost impossible without having any
sort absolutely so that's what that's
coming from we also want to do I take
supplements like vitamins and things
like that and I think that is what has
like helped me
yeah reach the next level so that's we
want to get to a point where we can grow
the company to put out special
supplements that will like we're cool
answers and in athletes like get to the
next level I feel like that's a huge
omission that doesn't exist no well not
against dancers for any sort of like no
female athlete this is clearly geared
towards females like gymnastics turns in
well at least exactly I stopped when I
was you know maybe 15 or something like
that but like when you're a kid you like
no one tells you what to eat or what to
do and then
sudden your coach will be like Oh
someone's looking a little hefty you
know like what I don't understand what
like I it's never a thing for you as a
young person to think about it until one
of your coaches or somebody says to you
that you should be eating differently or
doing something differently all of a
sudden it registers and then you get
crazy paranoid and your parents don't
understand like nobody understands they
just want to feed you because I love you
but you are making some sort of
sacrifice in your mind like you don't
really know what yeah exactly but this
is really smart for young girls where
being a certain size or weight or shape
is important for the or it's just like
let's not even debate that that's just a
thing it is plenty of sports swimming
not swimming but like diving like
anything you need to [ __ ] dancing
gymnastics oh my god oh you're so like
saying everything that was like went
into the NDI Jenna did gymnastics yeah
yeah in this incredible I mean I know
you're at gymnastics camp or whatever or
if you're like the serious about it that
means you've invested what six hours of
your day doing gymnastics and like the
on breaks like let's go to McDonald's
and then they're like you need to worry
about you know the way your legs are and
really well how do I even in bright
especially in the States are so
politically like right food is a touchy
subject you can't talk about it and you
can't talk about ideas yeah you can't
okay
anything anything and so I mean that's
where that comes from I want this
company to give me something that will
be for it not necessarily only for
females but for people who are in sports
that are worried about your aesthetic
and you need energy and you need them
safe and you're not going to be big
gulps of mayor for a living and I feel
like sports nutrition has existed for
sports right but there's nothing really
like sports nutrition is is just
starting to permeate the dance world
unlike only the best companies like a
royal ballet and like even the best
companies like Marine ski bullsh a
there's no like sports workout room I
was know like oh here's how you train
your body so that you don't get injuries
right you know it was just sort of like
a hit or miss I try and fail my
everything and like since I've had
injuries and like had to come back from
them that's I want to help people be
better at what they're doing you know
regardless so small steps I mean that's
two things one is you know I've known
about this product and the brand name
bro since we ate all what you know what
you guys not already be a professional
dancer in order to and enjoy that don't
have to man i hearing you talk about
that trying to create something that
doesn't exist and that gonna help so
many people
yeah ha that's awesome that's like the
best thing I could have ever hoped for
this thing me I didn't know number two
you you mentioned the supplements then
yeah
your mom is a genius he's amazing genius
I've had I've been affected by that
firsthand a doctor she's a doctor and
she's way more than I mean like when it
comes to her profession and everything I
had huge back problems do you remember I
remember it helped me through so much of
it I had the gluten issue she helped me
through so much I mean it's like she you
have been shaped by using supplements to
you're then to that to your very worst
engineers so I mean I've been taking
this set the stuff that my mom has
prescribed and it's worked like I mean
and and that's what I want to give to
you know to people I want them to be
able to you know be able to get their
injuries fixed and not do something
surgical that will like help them you
know like then you're done you're done
if you have surgery I have you know and
be able to be stronger and maybe we can
even raise raise the bar raise the bar
of dancing and women's acne yeah raise
the b8r re-dye cream of rice the crema
bar actually that's another one that's
like contestants are yeah yeah
are are you but there's aren't as good
as I'm sorry bar people sorry all right
sorry sorry not hard hard exactly
we're not sorry yeah well and we're here
no I was going to say this is this is
really cool and it takes a really
special person to you know you have a
love for dance a passion for dance
you'll never stop dancing never not even
in 92 just decide that you know what
else can I create out of my love and a a
product like this is really interesting
I think because not many people would
ever come up with that joy means they'll
be like okay well I'll come on how can I
create a dance studio
how can I do this I was just really
hungry and whatever but uh it's very
interesting and it's also interesting
the way that you're talking about your
future decisions and that you know you
really you lived in Russia for a long
time you accomplished so much there and
you're you're in this world where
there's only one path yeah and I am the
type of person that hates one path I
don't hate one path no I have infinite
maths don't you tell me I have one path
yes and I think that it's really
admirable of you to come from a world
where you have a cement patenting this
is the only path and you've decided to
say no I have lots of paths and I have
lots of choices and I will create
choices for myself even if it means
giving up something that's invested what
ten years yeah
no I mean like well not ten years but
like in Russia almost ten years in
Russia I mean for me I don't just want
to be a dancer and I think that it took
me going to Russia and like
understanding okay like one of my
passion well I'm passionate about
business and flashing about people -
well helping and I want to create right
whether it be YouTube videos or right
like dancing I just want to put content
out there um and I love dancing so I've
been really blessed to like get the best
training for them yeah um and I mean I
just think that you're so right when
you're like I don't want to be put in a
box right you put me in a box oh I can
break it out never
mark I'm going to break barriers and I
think that young children age 10 11 12
were like on their phones need to be
taught that like you need to do it
yourself red cannot have your mom drop
you off at soccer and you're going to be
a sorcerer that's not how it works you
know you've got to be passionate about
something yeah you guys are hearing this
from like absolute absolutely no no
you're really advocates can resume what
and you to get better advice them so
much like that I just think that it
would be really awesome to see more
dancers or like classical musicians like
people who are like people who are my
friends in Moscow are like amazing
amazing musicians they will wake up at
5:00 and practiced till 10:00 in the
morning then go home after their
whatever and like watches for another
play live and breathe it and yeah yeah
they don't make her why aren't those
people role models well it's well yeah
that's oh that's weird yeah we're
talking about how just having joy here
talking to her she's elite of elite of
elite you can't get a bigger person in
ballet than joy Womack and our culture
for some reason deems NFL the [ __ ]
basket but whatever some sports are
better than other sports are more
entertaining than other sports and it's
a little ridiculous we can sit and talk
with Joyce you know such wonderful
sounds and the popular things that are
they glorify being great know what
taking drugs nobody taking hungriest
Audrey is the hard work the hardest
working the hungriest the right well who
dedicate every second a cello all day
you talk to that guy track to Langley
right oh my god yo your mom one of the
most down-to-earth people you've ever
met like so approachable and it's like
why don't you have an entourage you know
like why are you like who is the rapper
who does the twerking thing like they're
like myleeza sorry I'm really straight
I'm a rapper that does the twerking um
no the like one with the really I don't
I don't know anybody
yes yeah yeah we talked about podcast
like okay sorry great good for you Nicki
Minaj like go from what you're doing but
like why are you and you have like
you're like rider with like 50 billion
things and like me and my partner he's
like a National Artist of Russia like
nobody knows who he is like I worked so
hard and he's like I'll make sure to
make sure to have some water yeah it's
like poor me no I pay my tickets yeah I
would pay to go to dance for you you
know like why I make I make 150 times a
month
like what for my hours a day yeah when
you yes like hey dollars a day like it's
just hilarious that somebody can like
like basically be like boopity boop boop
you know my cuz they have a big name and
they have people behind them now you
make like millions of dollars and you're
just like yeah why do I even try but at
the same time you have to try not
because you're getting money or fame
right
but because trying is the reason why you
should do it right the process is better
than the results the process is why it's
not oh I got like 85 billion likes on my
Instagram post or whatever like oh I
like I have so many friends on Facebook
right no it's about the sweat the blood
I got tears like these are [ __ ] balls
yeah it does it does get frustrating
sometimes when you see people that you
know maybe don't deserve to have that
many [ __ ] demands or have that much
money or where people they know mmm
about youtubers you know that would we
shouldn't we shouldn't be getting paid
at all we shouldn't be what is your sort
of money and I think it's always
frustrating to think about that you know
some people are much more deserving of
just a little [ __ ] help or a little
bit of [ __ ] recognition but it
doesn't make you what you're doing any
less important and when people do shift
their mindset and appreciate that the
people that love you your mom [ __ ]
Marsha yes I don't think you'll ever be
like a you know an icon globally but
like that appreciate
that appreciated love you to feel the
same way yeah like you mean a world to
them and yo yo mommy's new world to a
lot of people I'm not preaching
everybody needs to go to like a six-hour
opera yeah I won't do that
love you all friend man no I got it now
right and I think that like definitely
arts and culture like hello we're going
to open another can of worms like needs
to be taught in the states there has to
be exposure to it like I will talk to
people here in the states who are like
my friends and they're like so when are
you getting a real job yeah like also in
college
oh but the thing is the unites it that
to you yeah
no oh funny story okay friends very
great and I'm not in Austin like
recovering from like player rich plasma
therapy which is the best thing ever
um shout out to Tom and that when they
take like white blood cells yeah I take
your stem cells yeah and then they
injected in I should have been off for
six months I was back in T in a week on
punches on stage like it works
I'm shout out to who charm Austin yeah
turns evil it's leo
yeah it cost like 500 dollar take your
own stem cells yes where do they take
them from from your blood oh it's so
cool it's like the future that is so I
was in Austin and we're like at the
cycling Center meeting and like the guy
they're like so you would kind of like
went around the circle and like this in
the beginning and like explained like
who we were or whatever and then we get
to the end of the evening and they're
like we need to pray for joy I was like
why and they're like she's dancing at
the Kremlin I was it yeah and and
they're like yeah that's them that's a
strip club in insanity like two hours
even though she said we see the fringe I
think
we're getting the most ironic picture so
what we need arts education you name is
June my god these are college graduates
who don't know unplug dad sorry oh my
god that is hilarious
that's just like sorry that's just
proving my point but it's like oh I am
yeah I can't get over when people
anybody tells anybody to get a real job
yes it doesn't [ __ ] matter if you're
an artist on Venice Beach and you paint
pictures all the sudden be here my
medium is sidewalk chalk know whatever
and do your thing you do it and like
okay sorry when people get on youtubers
and say like oh that's not a real job
like me just whatever doing my little
dolly dinkle like I'm talking to my
iPhone I don't do but doing my dolly
dangles getting my dad you know um
like it just gave me such an
appreciation for what you and Julian do
people don't see the like all the stuff
that goes into it oh joy
hours which I'm like oh my gosh
it is more than a full-time job you go
to a full-time job you're like yeah you
know nine-to-five or whatever like
saying from my computer like actually
and playing The Sims you know I've done
that oh my god like on that these people
are passionate about what they do we
need to have more of that if you're
passionate about what you're doing then
you're happy yeah if you're like sitting
in front of a job you know like imma
lurks my mom and my grandma on beam to
be like why you're not doing your job
do you think you're being comfortable
you're not hungry at all
I'm passionate which is what I think
it's a great great thing that you're on
youtube and you're doing it because all
800 of the people who watch well you
know what I'm really going to go up Joey
and I'm serious and like the moment
people hear your story
they can't help but flop to win we're
doing all of what you're putting out
into the world and I know for myself I
absolutely can't wait to see what you do
with this and I'm really really shine
yeah it's gonna be good especially
watching we're gonna be watching we're
gonna be easy
II just remember seeing you every time
you're in town so I'm so sure you come
oh and my mom wants to see - I guess
what I haven't I'm not blaming you of
your music thank you quick like sidebar
here those pictures that your mom made
are like in the spot of honor in our
home so my mom does you know she does
porn so she did portraits of them when
we all lived in ceremony yeah and we're
chairs as a baby and it's like the only
pictures that actually get hanging out
better house changes like he's like a
really young teenager he's wearing is
like cutoff Nike shirt but he's like
Chloe facing yeah Chloe hey he looks
completely different now amazing joy
thank you so much okay so I can't tell
you guys know how much this meant to me
having grown this pocket so much I'm
like I'm like you guys can cry all
talking yeah check out squarespace.com
for my website needs they have awesome
templates 24-hour customer support 24
hours a day seven days a week you can
get chat customer support from
Squarespace you get on the tram they'll
help you out whatever problem everything
works on mobile everything works on
desktop they have online stores built in
it looks sexy is it oh they did the link
in our description so space.com you only
need a credit card to sign up really
well and you can catch joy at the
Kremlin in Austin I'm going to read no
San Antonio Johnny a women oh my god
that's the funniest story ever okay I'm
linking Joy's YouTube premium bar and
everything else she's working on in the
description I highly highly encourage
you to go check that out and see what
she does and you know I watch her blogs
they're very interesting and they're
only gonna get more interesting check
them out
your Instagram just the pictures of you
pausing places like you're likely oh my
god sailu but her likes like no she's
got to work thank you so much for having
me guys
it's been really really fun and AH thank
you guys for 50 episodes this is follow
them guys this is the best channel on
YouTube it's in the smash oh my god I
will see you guys next week for another
podcast I not buzzing you going back on
we will see you at VidCon all right
later guys